en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
comenzamos en el instituto weizmann de
ciencias de israel donde un grupo de
científicos aseguran que crearon lo que
serían los primeros embriones sintéticos
con células madre por lo que no se usó
ni óvulos y espermatozoides ni
fecundación la investigación liderada
por el biólogo celular palestino jake of
anna muestra que las células madre se
autoensamblan o auto organizan en
estructuras similares a las de los
embriones de laboratorio
el estudio muestra que puedes usar un
dispositivo especial que fabricamos un
medio especial que permite el
crecimiento natural de embriones de
ratón utilizando ese mismo sistema
podemos poner células madre que crecen
en un plato por largo tiempo las
ubicamos en estas condiciones y se
pueden auto organizar solas en ocho días
en un embrión completo el embrión para
el estudio se tomaron unas diez mil
células madre de ratón de ellas son los
50 lograron agruparse mediante el
dispositivo o incubado especial
desarrollado por los expertos que se
movía continuamente como un útero
materno esas 50 células se agruparon en
esferas y otras estructuras parecidas a
las de los embriones por lo que los
responsables describieron estas
creaciones como un 95% similares a los
embriones de ratón normales la mayor
importancia de esta técnica reside en
que en el futuro podría permitir
fabricar órganos que se requieran
reduciendo la posibilidad de rechazo del
cuerpo
el gran problema con los transplantes es
que necesitas encontrar un donante
compatible y el adn nunca es idéntico al
del paciente así que siempre habrá un
rechazo o debes tomar esteroides para
suprimir esa respuesta con este método y
si aplicamos diferenciación de las
células serán del mismo paciente es
decir el adn exacto sin necesidad de
donantes y no habrá rechazo nerz
no obstante una parte de la comunidad
científica reaccionó asegurando que
éstos no se pueden considerar embriones
por qué no en lugar a un individuo
viable que sea capaz de reproducirse
indican que la técnica tendría
importantes consecuencias éticas sin
embargo reconocen que si puede ser el
punto de partida para la fabricación de
órganos que sería el punto principal de
valor de esta investigación
hablamos ahora de realidad virtual
porque una experiencia inmersiva busca
que los fieles puedan visitar diferentes
sitios sagrados para distintas
religiones desde un recorrido por la
ciudad santa de jerusalén y la mezquita
de al-aqsa hasta una peregrinación al
muro de los lamentos y cava en la meca
se trata de viajes espirituales usando
esta tecnología
willy y es
creemos que la realidad virtual es por
así decirlo la nueva internet la nueva
forma en que las personas no ven las
cosas pasivamente en la pantalla y solo
hacen clic en fotos y videos sino que se
teletransporta ni atraviesan con un
determinado elemento de telepresencia
y así pueden ir y viajar y explorar y
tener una idea de los diferentes
rituales la arquitectura cultural tener
una idea del mundo sin la necesidad de
gastar muchísimo dinero
la experiencia incluye dos proyectos uno
bautizado the hollies ir y cuyo
desarrollo inició en 2015 y ahora a
través del método ver son los peregrinos
virtuales pueden seguir a clérigos
ortodoxos cuando salen de la iglesia del
santo sepulcro en la ceremonia del fuego
sagrado pueden introducir una oración en
una grieta del muro de los lamentos o
seguir los pasos de los fieles
musulmanes durante el ramadán en la
mezquita de al-aqsa de manera similar en
2015 la agencia digital visual comenzó a
crear una experiencia virtual que
permitiría a los visitantes con realidad
virtual peregrinar y explorar algunos de
los lugares más sagrados del islam
incluida la meca este proyecto fue
bautizado experience mch dresde onion
diréis john
hay una generación joven que es adicta
al teléfono móvil quería llegar a esa
generación e introducir el islam usando
la tecnología slam
entré en su espíritu el experience
en términos de experiencia espiritual te
acerca a la vida real de acuerdo pero de
ninguna manera es un reemplazo de la
experiencia en uruguay es ser placement
o shakespeare y la más reciente versión
se puede usar a través de google
cardboard un accesorio de bajo costo que
convierte a los teléfonos inteligentes
en visores de realidad virtual
y continuamos en italia donde robots
ayudan a científicos a monitorear el
medio ambiente de una manera más rápida
y eficiente son investigadores de la
universidad de pisa que están al frente
del proyecto inteligencia natural y
prueban un robot parecido a un perro que
trabaja inspeccionando en la salud de
las plantas y registrando el impacto de
los animales en su hábitat esto gracias
a las cámaras y sensores que también
permiten medir altura o determinar la
circunferencia de un árbol después de
dos horas de caminata el robot vuelve
automáticamente a la base para cambiar
de batería
se puede reprogramar pero por supuesto
tiene cierto nivel de autonomía y puede
decidir por sí mismo la parte
reprogramada es la región en la que el
robot debe realizar la misión de
monitoreo ambiental
eso ya está decidido por lo que hay una
gran red de regiones en europa donde se
debe realizar esta actividad de
monitoreo y dentro de cada punto que
haya sido seleccionado el robot tendrá
un cierto nivel de autonomía para
realizar su misión sin supervisión
without su posición todos los datos del
proyecto se transmiten a otros
departamentos y expertos para que sean
examinados cuidadosamente luego todo se
pone a disposición de colegas en europa
otro aspecto importante que tiene que
ser monitoreado específicamente son los
posibles daños causados por otras
especies en este caso animales que no
deberían estar presentes en un hábitat
determinado y que pueden dañarlo los
robots se utilizan tanto en tierra como
en el mar donde el acceso puede ser
complicado para los humanos
así concluimos este espacio a ustedes
gracias por su sintonía continúen con
nosotros
[Música]